今天想跟大家聊一個我覺得很有意思的案例。你可能沒想到，在網路這麼發達的現在，竟然會有人反其道而行，去開發一種「離線通訊」的應用程式。
離線通訊？現在還有這種東西嗎？大家不是都拚命追求更快更穩定的網路嗎？這做法聽起來有點出乎意料，感覺跟時代的潮流有點格格不入。
對，就是這種「格格不入」才讓我感到詫異。一般公司或個人，面對網路斷線，通常是想辦法解決斷線問題，或是尋找替代的線上方案。但他們卻是把網路斷線這個「限制」，變成一個新的商機。
怎麼說呢？網路斷線明明就是一種阻礙，把阻礙變成商機，這邏輯有點難理解。而且離線通訊，聽起來技術門檻很高，成本划算嗎？這模式撐得久嗎？
其實我一開始也不太看好，不過想了一下就想通了。這個 App 叫做 Bitchat，是 Twitter 共同創辦人 Jack Dorsey 在 2025 年推出的。它厲害的地方在於，即使沒有手機網路或網路連線，只要附近的手機，還是可以透過藍牙來通訊。
透過藍牙？那通訊距離不就很短嗎？這樣真的能大規模使用嗎？而且在印度這種國家，他們不是應該更需要穩定的網路來發展嗎？
這點我是信了，因為原文有提到具體數字。Bitchat 最重要的實戰，發生在印度新德里學生抗議期間。當時政府切斷了網路，但抗議者還是轉向使用 Bitchat，7 月 26 日就達到了 43 萬的每日活躍用戶，光印度就佔了全球下載量的 74%。
43 萬，這數字確實不小。所以政府切斷網路反而讓它爆紅了？那政府對這種 App 會有什麼反應？會不會直接把它禁掉？
你猜對了，政府當然不喜歡。原文提到，印度政府試圖封鎖 Bitchat 在 GitHub 上的原始碼。不過，根據數位公民權利非營利組織 Access Now 的資深政策顧問 Namrata Maheshwari 說，這種去中心化架構的 App 沒有中央伺服器，所以沒有「一鍵關閉」的開關。
喔，所以即使政府想封鎖，也很難完全禁用？這對創業者或主管來說，是不是能學到什麼？感覺就是把劣勢轉化成優勢，但具體可以怎麼運用？
我覺得，我們可以學到「韌性」和「反向思考」。面對外部挑戰，例如成本限制、資源不足，我們是不是也能像 Bitchat 一樣，從限制中找到新的解法，而不是只盯著問題本身？
你的意思是，如果我是一個小商店的老闆，房租很貴、人力有限，我不是要去拚命找便宜的店面，而是思考如何在有限的條件下，創造出獨特的價值？比如說，我的店面很小，但可以專注做外帶或預訂，把重點放在效率跟特色上？
沒錯，就像 Bitchat 把「網路斷線」這個痛點，變成「不受網路限制」的優勢。你開小店面，資源有限，就可以思考，如何把「小」這個限制，轉化成「精緻」「專屬」或「快速」的特色。
那一般上班族呢？這個概念可以帶入工作或生活嗎？感覺好像跟我們有點距離。
其實可以的。比如你的工作被規定只能用某個舊系統，你會抱怨它不好用，還是會試著用這個舊系統，去發掘它沒被用到的潛力，甚至因此發展出只有這個舊系統才能做到的工作模式？
聽你這麼一說，好像也提醒了我們，很多時候的限制，不見得是真正的限制，反而是讓我們重新思考的機會。